um
this is one of those interesting things
where directors often tell me that like
they have the movie pulled away from
them
but this is one of these situations
where you've had a ton of time to be
able to do post
what has it been like for you it's
definitely
the first time at first for for me in
this franchise you know i'm used to
going from final mix coming out of the
hitchcock stage at universal
seeing the sun come up jump in the car
go to the airport fly to london for the
uk premiere
you know and uh i think for us this time
to be able to sit and really kind of
play with
every frame um it's definitely the
silver lining i think in this in this
whole
journey to finish this film one of the
things i'm curious about is this is the
second to last film there's fast nine
and then fast 10.
from the inception did you guys design
this as a two-parter
knowing that this is basically near the
end
you know i i usually uh when we started
you know part of our philosophy was that
a sequel is not a given so let's do
whatever we can
and really kind of like service this
chapter and
you know it it it it it it worked really
well
but i think coming back and i think for
the last 10 years i've been talking to
vin and the subject
of like end of the saga end of the saga
it was just kind of something we
discussed
and i have to say that you know coming
back this is the first time i've allowed
myself to say okay well let's talk about
it as the final chapter
and we knew that the real estate was
gonna expand past one film
and so it's been very liberating to be
able to kind of work
you know and to allow ourselves to
really kind of think that way
you're basically saying it ends on a
cliffhanger what
[Laughter]
it could be anything so uh what
i joke around about this but i've been
wondering who's going to get to
outer space first the fast and furious
franchise or tom cruise
[Laughter]
what will it take for the fast franchise
to get to outer space
is it in fast 9 or could it be in fast
10
you know i i think through the years you
know it's part of the fun
is is to come up with crazy ideas to
challenge ourselves
you know um but i i have to say i think
you know
we never do it just for the sake of
shock value
or just to you know just it always takes
something from the theme or the
character journey and i i could say that
you know when i was working on fast nine
there was a thread that felt very
appropriate
to to take us to places we've never gone
to
and uh i drove to vin's house and i sat
down with them and we looked at each
other and we're like okay
this is the one this is the one that
we're gonna try and it felt very
appropriate
and so you know i kind of can't wait to
kind of share with the world because
you know the more we kind of push and
and do crazier
you know stunts and set pieces i think
the more
we have to check ourselves to make sure
we earn that i'm a huge listen there's a
lot of characters to fill in this movie
and i'm listen i love this franchise uh
and i'm always curious about the editing
room can you talk about
like how how long is the movie and did
you end up with a lot of deleted scenes
um
the movie is is i don't know what the
final count was
um it definitely i could tell you
you know this movie could have been six
hours if we wanted to
you know it because there's i love all
these characters
and and and and you know i i think a lot
of times
when i sit down with each actor when we
talk about the character
it always sucks because so much of what
we talk about we never see on screen
you know and so to be able to revisit a
lot of these characters
it was so for you know i to me was so
fulfilling
um but at the same time i can't i wanted
to have more real estate i wanted to
have more real estate
but i think we were very disciplined i
think part of it for me
is to know that you know we're not
treating this as one film
you know and so um i think there's a lot
i mean there's a lot we're exploring
um you know i think we're exploring this
idea of sibling rivalry and conflict
uh you know family by blood for the
first time
on on part nine and to be able to to do
that
but also at the same time bring a lot of
these characters back
there's a lot going on you know and so
um
i i feel good talking to you now because
i know
that you know we're we were talking
about it in in multi-films as opposed to
just one film
yeah you could give me a three-hour
version of fast nine i'll take it
[Laughter]
i mean this is not a problem just hook
me up the vein is right here
you know um i i gotta go but
hopefully it's a long movie i really
want to enjoy this
it's definitely uh it's very meaty i'll
tell you that
cannot wait